have you ever watched a cartoon and
recognized the voice behind one of the
characters and became
extremely frustrated when you couldn't
place it if so you're not alone it can
be
maddening to determine where you
recognize a voice when you can't see
their face
in this video we'll cover popular
cartoons from your childhood and where
you might have heard the voice of
characters before
as you'll see many actors and actresses
voice various roles in hollywood making
it easy to recognize their voice
every day should be a roller coaster you
know what i know we're gonna do today
we're gonna build a roller coaster on
phineas and ferb one of the main
characters is candace
she is phineus older sister and ferb
stepsister you might find candace's
voice familiar because it's the voice of
a very popular disney star
this actress was also a part of the high
school musical series the suite life of
zach and cody's show and the hellcat
show
if you haven't guessed yet candace's
voice is played by ashley tisdale ashley
is a total childhood inspiration because
of her feminine sparkly and
girly style who didn't want to be just
like ashley as a kid
hello bustom do i have a show for you
another major character on the phineas
and ferb cartoon was phineas flynn
no duh his name is in the title of the
show the actor who voices phineas isn't
as well known as ashley tisdale because
he hasn't played a lot of serious roles
however he's played parts on well-known
movies and tv shows like everybody hates
chris
role models and the walking dead if you
haven't been able to guess yet
phineas is voiced by vincent martella
even though vincent hasn't always landed
major roles he's no stranger to
hollywood in fact you might notice his
name more now that you know that he was
behind phineas flynn's character
oh cool our moon elevator mom would love
this
another classic childhood cartoon is the
fairly odd parents
sometimes in cartoons actors and
actresses voiced more than one character
this was precisely the case on the
fairly oddparents as
wanda and mrs turner is voiced by the
same woman you might not recognize this
actress because she mainly does voice
acting instead of on-screen acting she's
done work for other animations in action
movies like shrek bioshock and
spider-man the voices of wanda and mrs
turner is voiced by the one and only
suzanne blakesley
you might be surprised that timmy turner
from the fairly oddparents is actually
voiced by a girl
not a boy but if you think about it
timmy was a young boy so it makes sense
for his character to be voiced by a
woman
because the voice would be more
appropriate than a deep man's voice
the woman who voices timmy has done
extensive work behind the scenes of
cartoons which is why you might
recognize it she's the voice from the
powerpuff girls as bubbles and raven
from teen titans if you don't know the
name it's tara strong
tara also did the voices for poof and
tad on the fairly oddparent show
i mean let's get you apart so what do
you want me to do vicky
that brings us to the next childhood
cartoon sensation the powerpuff girls
we know who's behind bubble's voice but
what about the other girls from the
powerful trio
buttercup is another girl from the
famous cartoon that you might recognize
the voice actress was also behind tommy
pickles in rugrats she's done work
elsewhere too like in the movie happy
feet and on the tv show curious george
the voice actress behind all these
characters is elizabeth daly she's a
talented voice actress but she's also
played roles on the big screen
yeah it's wheels for the win
the final girl from the powerpuff girls
trio is blossom
an interesting fact about the voice
actress who voices blossom is she's
also a redhead you might recognize her
voice from the tom and jerry show as she
voices toodles mom the actress has done
lots of other voice acting work for
video games and cartoons if you don't
know who she is her name is
kathy cavadini keep an eye out for her
name as you'll likely see it pop up
somewhere
i can see why the possibilities are
endless next up on the list of nostalgic
childhood cartoons is jimmy neutron boy
genius
just like timmy turner jimmy's voice was
actually a woman's not a man's the voice
actress behind jimmy
also made an appearance on icarly played
the voice of wednesday adams on the old
tv show
and voice diana on sailor moon she's
been a part of a ton of other film
creations and has built
quite an extensive resume her name is
debbie dairyberry even though you might
not recognize her name you'll definitely
recognize her voice as she's done
tons of work i should be able to use the
baby quackers remote to control the
malibu death machine
one of the recurring characters on jimmy
neutron is commander baker the voice
actor behind commander baker hasn't done
a lot of cartoon work but he has done a
lot of action and drama movies
throughout his career his biggest movies
are armageddon
planet of the apes and the green mile
the actor behind commander baker is none
other than michael clark duncan himself
this would be a hard voice to place
since he hasn't done a ton of cartoon
work
i'm prepared to cry and beg teen titans
is another childhood memory that many of
us 1990s and 2000s kids remember
one of the memorable characters from
teen titans is beast boy the voice actor
of beast
boy also played the voice of
michelangelo on teenage mutant ninja
turtles and stink fly on ben 10.
as you can see this voice actor has had
a lot of experience with sci-fi and
action cartoons later on in life
this actor went on to do some action
movies like fast and furious
if you don't know who this actor is yet
his name is greg sipes
whose voice does you do yours fool
another major character from teen titans
is slade the voice actor that embodies
slade isn't someone who normally takes
on voice acting roles he's been a part
of the hellboy transformers
and sons of anarchy series however he's
also taken on some small roles with kim
possible
archer and adventure time the man behind
slade's voice is none other but ron
pearlman
now that you know his name the powerful
face and jawline of ron
might remind you of the big roles he's
played before i'm not
through rugrats is one of the all-time
unforgettable cartoon favorites of
children from the 1990s and 2000s you
obviously know that what you might not
know is that there's a famous actress
who voiced the small role of taffy
she's acted on mega iconic movies like
what a girl
wants she's the man hairspray and big
fat liar if the actress's name
isn't coming to you yet she was also the
star of the amanda show
and her name is amanda bynes even though
taffy from rugrats isn't a big role
amanda did a great job with her voice
but i'm bummed i'm missing kimmy's b-day
party i promise i'll make it up to her
the bigger roles of the rugrats shows
weren't played by big name actresses
although they've had successful careers
in their own way kimmy is one of the
characters from the rugrats show that
you
might recognize the voice of the voice
actress also voiced trixie tang from the
fairly oddparents
and yasmin from the show bratz she's
also done voice acting work for video
games and other
cartoons such as curious george the
voice actress's name
is dion kwan
but you can't sleep without him science
lovers were probably a big fan of
dexter's laboratory as a kid
dexter's voice was played by a woman to
capture the youthful voice of a boy
character
this voice actress goes way back she's
appeared in the movies jerry maguire and
babe
she also did the voice for whizzer from
101 dalmatians
and chucky finster from rugrats which is
why you might recognize dexter's voice
if the name hasn't popped into your head
yet it's christine kavanagh
oh can it be true
do you remember the tv cartoon hey
arnold if so grandpa was one of the
recurring characters that you might
recall
this actor's voice is definitely
recognizable because he also does the
voice of homer from the simpsons and
jonathan from rugrats he's done
extensive work for other cartoons and
films throughout his career the voice
actor's name is dan castellaneta keep an
eye out for dan's name as he does
a lot of work in hollywood oh well shoot
short man
next up on the list is the cartoon
adventure time with finn and jake
adventure time had a very unique
animation which made it popular among
children and even teens
finn's voice was played by a young voice
actor he's also worked on the voltron
series as lance and
batman the brave and the bold tv show is
robin his name is jeremy shaida if you
don't know jeremy
definitely look him up because he is a
total heartthrob mysterious
oh brought something for the party two
of the other big characters on adventure
time are ice king and gunter these two
characters were voiced by the same actor
you probably will recognize his voice
because the actor also did spongebob
squarepants voice
he's also done voices on rick and morty
final space bojack horseman and american
dad which is probably why his voice
sounds so familiar the man behind all
these personas is tom kenny tom has also
done work on many other cartoons and
films
making him well known in hollywood
circles you know where it is
lead the way one of the lesser known
cartoons from the 1990s and 2000s is
total drama island but if you watched it
you might remember chef hatchet the
voice behind chef hatchet went on to do
a bunch of crime dramas and thriller
movies such as
jigsaw urban legend and bait even though
cartoons aren't his thing he did an
excellent job with chef hatchet's voice
the man behind the character is clee
bennett clee's most recent roles on tv
have been the man in the high castle and
the tick
sage the supernumerary another awesome
cartoon is disney's gravity falls
mabel pines is one of the main
characters and this voice actress has
done work on other big time cartoons and
movies
she's the voice of sarah lynn on bojack
horseman and louise belcher on bob's
burgers she's also appeared in adventure
time
norbit and the muppets movie her name is
kristen shaw
if you don't know who she is definitely
remember her name as she's part of a lot
of new movies and tv shows
he said mabel give about a doorbell
another character from disney's gravity
falls is lazy susan you might recognize
lazy susan's voice because this actress
has also appeared on a cinderella story
as the evil stepmom
legally blonde as paulette and american
pie as stiffler's mom these are some
pretty big roles so it's hard
to miss the girly and preppy voice all
of these characters are played by none
other than jennifer coolidge
oh the hide behind is definitely real
how could we skip over the cartoon kim
possible
kim was definitely a powerful icon for
girls with an inner tomboy one of the
other characters on the show is dr
draken the voice behind dr draken is
probably familiar because this voice
actor has done many other voices such as
a bender from futurama king zog from
disenchantment
jake from adventure time and manly dan
from gravity falls the voice behind all
these characters
is john dimaggio john has quite an
impressive resume as he's worked on many
cartoons and action films
i believe some introductions are in
order here last on this list but
definitely not least is disney's recess
gretchen grundler is one of the cartoon
characters from the recess playground
this voice actress has appeared on
several iconic cartoons such as teen
titans as tara ben tennis gwen
and renee from teenage mutant ninja
turtles later on in her life she's acted
in many live-action movies such as the
avengers and the last of us if you don't
know her name it's ashley johnson
dematerialized just like at a star trek
that brings us to the end of our list of
voices behind nostalgic cartoon
characters you might not recognize all
of the voice actor and actresses names
but
definitely keep them in mind as they'll
likely appear again
if you're curious about more cartoon tv
and film facts don't forget to subscribe
to the things thanks for watching
you